أثبتت قوات الأمن العراقية أنها غير قادرة
على الدفاع عن عدد من المدن مما
سمح للإرهابيين باجتياح جزء
من أراضي العراق
مدثا ليتي سان عوض من صاحب خلية
أمريكا باراك أوباما
الكاتيل أمريكا أمينة لارا يوكولان إلياس
ماتاتا سياتل مادونا ميا خصي
للتوجه إلى  إصبع القدم مال مال أمريكا
أوباما أو مستشاري أنت تعرف كيزونا
هيرات في مانهاتن رائعتين استمتع بغرابة
إلمو لارا تيم أوهارا حيث
تمرد مارتن سني 18 هنا - أسهل كثيرًا في
هوائيات ألما ماريا مدينا تينا راكيا
لماذا - هاكاما تيلابيا
لانتا صلالة له أسانا تيلمان  LJ seal
America Milania قرار المنزل شفويًا
المالكي الكافيار الفاسد بمرارة يجب
أن نظهر استعدادنا لاتخاذ
قرارات صعبة
فاكا أوم المالكي ليفاتور 18 - isla de
wattle pmbus of catty Tov a cos Ultima
moon sec he minal muslimeen a son who I
Asafa  hatun lot جنبًا إلى جنب مع محفظة ethyl ester
إذا كان قد تأخر Alva nieta Venus
Palma Ceia إلى إيران صالحًا
لإرقاء على تحليل G Mennen r-rahim la miel masa  لا
شنيعة una y um زورق وإلى جانب
أمريكا غنت هو هاليد فلوريدا المالكي
الموسى واما وافل وارتون إف سي
وكابادوكيا موراي يو إن سي a ساتا أوباما لا
كولين في الشيشة الاسمية كابا آدم أو
تركيا تمايل المخصي أمريكا أنا
أوباما من أجل واهو -  o تدرس في ساموا
اللاتينية أوروبي ليبرالي موزيلي
الجهاد اللاموزا غريب الأطوار وبالنسبة له
دورة قصيرة أفضل